is it the greatest discovery of our time
it must be up there i suppose if it
turns out to be really what they think
they've found if it's true it's huge
and but there's just one piece of
evidence for it at the moment the
measurement that they've made is of the
polarization of the cosmic microwave
background so cosmic microwave
background is this leftover radiation
from the big bang and polarization is
this fact that you know photons can sort
of have an orientation associated with
them to do with the direction in which
their electric fields are oscillating
and it could be up and down or left and
right or whatever and this is very
characteristic signature that they've
detected in the cosmic microwave
background where there's a pattern of
polarization on the sky so you measure
the polarization of the light that's
coming from one bit of sky and another
bit of sky and another bit of sky and so
on and you end up with this very
characteristic pattern of sort of a
spiral of polarization potentially we're
probing
the very very very early universe about
10 to the minus 35 seconds it's called a
b mode because it looks a bit like a
magnetic field sort of type structure as
opposed to an e mode which are the ones
that kind of stick radially outwards and
they look a bit like an electric field
but the the b mode polarization this
very characteristic pattern is a
signature of inflation which is this
process in the very early universe
whereby we went from a very small
universe up to a very large universe
very quickly i've not come across it
quite like this there was the build up
for the higgs and that was that had a
lot of press associated with it but that
had a gradual development of tentative
evidence of a detection and then a few
months later more evidence
this is bang
we found it so the the origins of this
is one of the byproducts of inflation is
you end up imprinting uh gravitational
waves into the early universe so these
oscillations of space itself
and so it's the imprint of those
gravitational waves that you see in the
polarization signature this particular
experiment bicep
which is down in the
south pole
has
probably had the highest sensitivity
of all the experience looking for this
thing and so maybe it's not surprising
that they're the first ones to find any
evidence
of
what we interpret as gravitational waves
i mean that's exciting in itself it's
you know it's one of the one of the
predictions of inflation is that these
primordial gravitational waves should be
there and this is the signature of them
what are gravitational waves these are
new are they
no they've been around ever since
einstein wrote down is well they've been
around since the beginning of the
universe but we've known about them ever
since einstein wrote down his
field equations that describe how space
time and matter interact with one
another there are various people in the
in the gravitational wave community who
are quite annoyed about this new story
because it's been you know headlined as
this is the first detection of
gravitational waves and of course there
was the binary pulsar which is pair of
pulsars in orbit around one another
which because there are a couple of
objects in orbit around one another
giving out gravitational waves and so
they're losing energy so they're
spiraling in together and that spiraling
in together has already been detected
and has already won the nobel prize and
so in that sense gravitational waves
have already been detected but these are
the primordial gravitational waves and
in some sense this is slightly more
direct detection on them you're still
not seeing the gravitational waves
themselves but you're seeing kind of a
fairly direct signature of the
gravitational waves and they're
basically fluctuations in the space time
and waves propagating because of
fluctuations in the space time due to
the influence of of matter but now there
has been a detection it's not a direct
detection of gravitational waves but
it's almost as good as it
it's like saying i think the analog is
saying we all seem to be happy that we
found the higgs
well no one saw the higgs the higgs had
decayed in 10 to the minus 20 seconds or
something we saw the products of its
decay which we thought we understood and
this is an example of that that uh the
in certain theories of the of the early
universe in particular inflationary
theories we expect there to be these
ripples in the background space time
producing these gravitational waves
which are then propagated since 10 to
the minus 35 seconds
and they influence the space time as
they're going through and they can
distort it and stretch it compress it
and so photons of light that go through
this they get what's known as polarized
by by the presence in a very particular
way by the presence of the this grease
gravitational waves and by looking for
the particular polarization patterns
then you infer that you have evidence of
these gravitational waves and it's that
that this wonderful quite amazing
experiment has seems to have found
evidence for your job is studying
galaxies galaxy formation and evolution
is there anything about this discovery
by bicep if it turns if it stands
that will
trickle through to your work is this
useful to you well in some sense so if
inflation happened then actually the
sort of the seeds
everything got blown up enormously in
scale which means that
things on the the quantum scale the
microscopic scale got blown up to
macroscopic scales so actually the if
you like the primordial seeds from which
all the structure in the universe formed
the galaxies the large scale structure
the clusters and all that
were actually caused by this
inflationary process of starting from
microscopic quantum mechanical things
and blowing them up to the scales that
we can see it so in that sense the sort
of a
sort of first cause if you're looking
for as to where galaxies first came from
it's in the south pole it's not a huge
experiment it's but it's basically um
you know a big telescope but it's
sensitive to polarized light it targets
small patches of the sky it doesn't do a
full all-sky survey like say the planck
satellite has done it targets small
patches of the sky and it just looks at
the microwave radiation coming to it
from those regions of the sky and it
looks for
patterns in the polarization perhaps in
the more immediate term there's also
this issue that
probably the
the remaining biggest degree of
skepticism about this detection is
whether they're really seeing a
primordial b mode effect or whether it's
something that was imprinted more
recently then they do the analysis of
this they have to extract out all the
foregrounds all the spurious things that
can also create polarized light and wait
to see if they have a residual signal
that they can't account for by anything
else and in particular one of the things
that people who study the cosmic
microwave background worry about a great
deal of foreground things that have
nothing to do with the cosmic microwave
background and in fact our own galaxy
the milky way is a major source of
foregrounds and there's plenty of
polarized photons being produced in the
milky way because there are magnetic
fields in the milky way and lots of
things that produce polarization so one
of the things these guys have to do very
carefully is take out all those
foregrounds and so it could be that
actually galaxies are the things that
are messing up this signal rather than
the thing that that you know some
fundamental way being produced by it on
the scale on the sky which is about one
degree in the sky so if you imagine
looking at the sky and picking out one
degree patches then these are the sizes
of the of the signals the the regions of
which these signals are found and they
they that matches very well predictions
from
theories of inflation that these
theories many of them suggest that
you should be finding evidence of these
what do we call primordial gravitational
waves primordial because they were
formed in the very old universe on a
scale of about one degree or so
and so there's a there's there's a hope
that that's what we're actually seeing i
think i think if if it holds
if the result holds and the
interpretation of the result in terms of
we're seeing evidence of these
gravitational waves being produced in
the first 10 to the minus 35 seconds
what you're seeing is
a the furthest back anyone can possibly
see right just two orders of magnitude
below the planck scale
your
you're then probing physics that we've
got no other way of probing we'll have
no way of really probing this
accelerators they can't reach this kind
of energy
and we've got a way of kind of
understanding it if it's confirmation of
inflation it means we've got a way of
understanding the big bang i'm not the
right person to talk to you to answer
this question but
my level yeah at my level of
understanding you you go through a phase
of the expansion of the universe where
the whole thing expands incredibly
rapidly exponentially rapidly so you end
up with this
starting from you know the very small
regions blocked to become extremely
large regions of the universe
and this solves all sorts of problems
about our understanding of the universe
for example we do have this problem that
if you look at the cosmic right wave
background in that direction and the
cosmic microwave background in that
direction they're almost identical to
each other they have exactly the same
temperature exactly the same structure
those two bits of the universe have
never been in causal contact with one
another they have never actually had a
chance to talk to each other if you
don't have inflation and and so how did
that bit of the universe know to have
exactly the same temperature as that bit
of the universe if they've never
actually been close enough together to
kind of exchange that information
whereas inflation is a way of actually
things which are no longer in causal
contact with one another in the very
early universe before they inflated
really were in contact with one another
and so this causes this solves this
problem as to how the universe can be as
uniform as it is when you're looking at
things which shouldn't actually have
ever had an opportunity to talk to each
other have they just found this
polarized light and said
we reckon this is passed through these
primordial gravitational waves
hooray we found gravitational waves or
have they used the
the mapping of this light to tell us
something about those waves it's it's
they've both
they've done both things because the
the first thing that they've done is by
looking at these patterns of of the
polarization that how the
the the lines of polarization go around
these hot and cold spots they're able to
determine that what they're seeing is
actually known as b mode polarization
it's just a technical term
but the key thing is that the b modes
can be
um in the from inflation b modes are
only produced by gravitational waves it
was well set up as a you know they they
trailed it cleverly because actually
they you know there was a bit of mystery
going around so there's a bit of
interest as to what is it they're going
to announce and it is a big deal right
it's a hugely big deal to understand
this fundamental piece of physics and
whether it's really but they did it
extremely well which i suspect is why it
got picked up by the media as as
strongly as he did because they actually
you know they set it up in the right way
and they had all the right stuff in
place so that when the story came out
the media was all set to go with it
gravitational waves just propagate
that's that's the most beautiful thing
in sense in some sense of gravitational
waves they they don't they don't get
cancelled out by anything and they can
propagate through the universe they
interact with matter and they through
einstein's equations and they just
propagate they don't get absorbed and
you you lose them you can do the best
science in the world and if you then
don't present it in a way that the world
can understand then you know it's just
going to stay in the dusty filing
cabinets the the problem with light
you know what how far back in the
universe can we see well we can see to
the origin of that cosmic background
radiation we can see back to when the
universe was about 380 000 years old
and but beyond there we can't see the
universe becomes opaque and because all
the light keeps scattering across the
the ionized plasma that lived before
that period
gravitational waves don't care about the
ionized plasma gravitational waves don't
care about the density of the material
they just propagate through and so
that's the fantastic thing what we've
got here
if it works out and now that the
technology is reaching the levels where
you can
regularly see these
this signal is we have a new telescope
if you like this probing through the
cosmic microwave background past that
era and back to the earliest moments and
then the other really neat thing about
the gravitational waves is that if it's
from inflation say is that what you're
really finding evidence for is the
energy scale of the early universe when
did inflation occur
and it seems to have occurred as i said
about 100 you know 100th of a planck
scale this is a typical scale that you
associate with what is called
unification where you unify all the
forces of nature and one of the goals of
theoretical physics is to unify gravity
and
the weak interactions the
electromagnetic interactions and the
strong force
and it's believed that the area where
they will be most likely unified are
called grand unified scales
and the favorite candidates are up at
about 10 to the 16.
it's called 10 to the 16 giga electron
volts 10 to the 16 billion electron
volts
this is now and now what we're saying i
think is any decent unification theory
had better take on board inflation as
well
it better figure out how to incorporate
inflation into your particle physics so
that we can properly understand
unification of forces one of the major
goals of theoretical physics you have to
be very careful about it you can't just
go throwing stories out before you
really have analyzed the data to death
and really understood exactly what's
going on but that's what these guys did
right they put a huge amount of work in
they've had the data for years now
they've been worrying about all these
things that we've just been talking
about about the foreground and whether
they really are detecting what they
thought they were and whether they're
instrumental effects and so on so
they've done all their work and at that
point you have to then put it out to the
world and that's what they did the other
interesting thing is that not only do
they have this big press conference but
they actually released all their data as
well so there's a whole bunch of
scientists all around the world now who
are all busy pouring over their data
just to make sure that there aren't any
sort of show stoppers that they've
missed what is the point i mean it's
very fundamental physics right it's
really understanding how the universe
came into being in the first place and
it's going to have implications for you
know these people who think that there
might be a multiverse might be multiple
universes out there also connects in
with the ideas of inflation and so on so
in some sense it's really very in at a
very fundamental level telling us where
we came from it's the origins of the
universe
is understanding the origin of the
universe
gonna change the price of milk no
probably not but it's just you know it's
it's in that sense it's sort of the
connections between science and
philosophy it's about understanding the
real origins of the universe it's
probably in some sense it's the biggest
question you could ever hope to answer
and and as with a lot of big questions
it doesn't have direct implications for
everyday life but it just sort of
changes your outlook on the world a bit
a few nanoseconds after the actual
initial singularity
the big bang has certain assumptions in
it i'm going to come to inflation why
you need inflation and what it is the
big bang has certain assumptions in it
it's based on what is called the
cosmological principle which is
something einstein introduced